how come you don't support uh term
limits
i we have them in new york and they
don't really work
chiefs of staff run for the last
position for the person
passing you and then they become
inherently the chief of staff it doesn't
actually create
massive change in bureaucracy oh so you
see people in the administration take
the old role yeah it happens all the
time like it literally it's just cycling
the same nonsense you don't really see
like
i mean we do have some things in new
york we have a campaign finance laws
where we do matching funds or you do
have some
people run for office that's handled to
an extent but they do try to do a good
job so
i i do have one idea that i think you
know i know a lot of people talk about
term limits and we go back and forth on
whether to work or not
um we could just hear me out take
a a giant uh spaceship like the one that
elon musk has created
put all of the politicians on it and
send it to mars
and then just go about our business i
was on a bachelor party trip and why
this one guy randy paul can stay though
and he was a big stoner he was like guys
we just stopped paying taxes we won't
have a government anymore we want to
play paintball and he was shot the first
10 seconds of every game he goes
he goes bro that happens i'm ko like
don't even bother calling me anymore
yeah i don't know it's a very hard thing
to sit there and do but there are very
practical things the government could be
i was
i was on my way here and we're on a road
with
stretches of acres of land on both sides
of us and there's traffic and it's two
lanes i'm like right this is
one thing if there's the government
could build an extra lane like i'd be
okay with it no one would sit there and
protest
one extra lane i don't there's plenty of
land i get if you're like there's no
place to build but there is or tunnels
i mean you want to build let's create a
jobs program united states
just multi-layer roads like you know
chicago's got upper and lower whacker
something i shouldn't be able to sit
cool by the way i shouldn't just sit in
mass amounts of traffic
and this is the problem is that
people would be okay with the
government's nonsense if they did the
bare minimum
the quality of life thing if i wasn't in
the nation's capital
walking my dog on a block with nine
homeless people who are talking
themselves
if we could just solve the basics people
excuse a lot
i really do feel like our government at
this point
is like you know it started out with
someone creating you know christmas
lights
and they're and they're rolling them up
real perfectly and then each time they
hand off the roll of christmas lights
they get a little more tangled
and now this is like where we're at like
you know five six generations seven
generations
and we're just holding this big bundle
thing and we're like we don't even know
what connects to what or like where that
goes
and everyone's arguing about how to
untangle it but no one can figure out
what's going on it gets to a point where
once you receive a tangled ball you just
assume that it's tangled by nature you
don't even get
yes and it's also right and that's the
way it's always been and it's also the
people who want to untangle it the most
are like well what does what does
procedure say
and what what should we do what's in the
what's in what's in the constitution
what we can do not oh what power can we
just sit there and use boldly to sit
there
and and now we have to ask bureaucracy
to be to
lower themselves and that's why local
governments are more responsive because
they're they are smaller but because
they are they
it's literally like what service can you
provide immediately not like these long
you know alienated beliefs that no one
is i think we've just got uh you know
this jumbled up system of a bunch of
criss-crossing weird laws and rules and
regulations that are confusing everybody
but that's what but what happened and i
wrote this in the book by the way and i
talk about this constantly in my in my
newsletter at the national poppies
newsletter
is that what happened in all these other
countries was finally it was enough
and they voted for these outside parties
that are that are very radical in their
beliefs and how they do it
now we have a first-past-the-post system
which is like you have to get the
majority in your individual district so
it's a little different it's a little
harder to have that
but we're seeing changes within the
two-party structure that are saying
it just doesn't work for us and yeah
some of those people are the aocs of the
world and they're
like you know nuts and then some of the
people are you know real reformers who
want to do something and we may
see them coming out who sit there and
say to like you know the libertarians in
the world like oh great you know
government can be used for something
good i don't think elsie's nuts
i think she's more what's what's the
word for
when you want to trick people into
stealing from them
you know yeah that that that's right
yeah bribery subservient who's that guy
who's just deceitful
oh okay i was joking uh she just
contradicts herself and says whatever
her audience time wants to hear he
doesn't actually have debated yeah like
when she was like trump
is running concentration camps legal
asylees
have broken no law and the guy is like
what's his name home and what's that
guy's name and he's like
they broke section 23. he like just
write it out to her
and then when joe biden gets elected and
they reopen the homestead facility she
says
detention center you know immigration
facilities with controversial records
what a great leap from concentration
camp my problem with populism is when
you get a backlash to enact or
you know faulty systems and then you
just get some really popular person that
doesn't know what they're doing like
that's not what powers would like like
cortez or like
she's like now you got pol pot you got
hitler that's not no but it's all
popular
yeah but they weren't most of those
people you just mentioned were not
democratically elected
or like legit i mean hitler was democrat
well he has seized power but he was
leaving but he was but mao was not
democratically elected to sit there in
his position a lot of them aren't
um yes and there are some very bad side
effects i mean
uh chavez was democratically elected
yeah there are but there are also people
who are democratic elected
like you know orbin in in hungary people
aren't being marched into concentration
camps he's not
i mean as horrible as people say it
isn't in hungary what did he do he said
to women oh if you want to stay home and
have kids i'll give you a social
security check
and uh like i mean yes and
it started yeah we were scientifically
changed but like yeah there are people
who do radically terrible things
but it's also like owning a gun yeah
some people are nuts and they shouldn't
be holding a firearm and
some people are genuine and can actually
do something with the power you go
look you know we're at this point where
you've got the democratic party wholly
embracing black lives matter and
the left wholly embracing black lives
matter and the symbol that they fly on
their flags
is literally the symbol of communism it
is the red salute
yeah that is a fact and they'll tell you
it doesn't mean that it means something
else i'm like
shut up if somebody marches around doing
the roman salute i'll call the guy a
nazi
they're not gonna play any stupid games
with me they're holding up the red
salute
that's what they do they put it on their
flags a guy tattooed on his neck and
then went and shot a trump supporter
we are looking at extremists they don't
care
they're not going to argue with you you
this is the problem conservatives have
is they think they're arguing with
someone who's interested yeah they think
they're going and sitting down with the
guy who's literally got
the red salute tattooed on his neck and
they're like but hear me out here's why
i think this
is wrong and they're like i'm i'm
interested i'm actually arguing in good
faith
have you ever read the federalist papers
no that is exactly i tell us all the
time conservatives you're playing a game
that there's
that they're not following the rules
like you are literally playing chess and
there's now we'll just move any pieces
we want that's right
i don't see populism functioning in the
democratic party
in that bernie sanders i thought was for
sure going to be a nominated and elected
in 2016 and then that happened and then
20 2020 again
but because of super delegates this
ridiculous like
totalitarian decision-making process
in the beginning yeah when the when the
bird landed on his podium i was like oh
gandhi
and the hillary email thing it was just
insanity yeah
yeah no it's it's uh that's where that
came from that bird i just didn't know
that the bird landed on his podium yeah
i remember but i was talking about i
didn't make sense
like dude i'm it's like like levitating
the pentagon like i'm seeing things
right how amazing was it though
how did you feel ian after uh bernie was
you know fighting the system and the
bird landed
and then he got up on the stage and was
like i'm going to now get on my knees
and lick the feet of hillary clinton i
cried but i was so sad i couldn't cry
it was in my it was in my gut but that
just i laughed that just shows like
there's like no honest leftist left
like back in the day there would have
been an honest love just like you know
screw you and
the dumb ones are honest they're just
they don't understand they don't have
power though
yeah but like the aoc is endorsing biden
going along with it i mean
if you're this big revolutionary you
don't do that like this
this this you know this this is the big
problem there was this thing posted on
twitter by
shu on head about she posted this thing
where it was like the more i read the
more i scroll
and it was like the guy turning into
style or whatever and it was a github
thing where it's like let me show you in
inches
the wealth of jeff bezos or whatever and
it said like in one day
jeff bezos made 13 billion dollars and
it's like
no he didn't anyway and then it's like
here's how much you need to
uh home all homeless veterans and i'm
like money doesn't put homeless veterans
in homes
these are children all right this is
what what bothers me is like i'm not
going to have a debate with someone
who's like
there's like homeless people were like
why don't we just put them in a house
like that's so dumb like
you could just you put them in the house
it's like do you know why people are
homeless
mental illness and then drug abuse
number two number one and not only and
that is working poor as well
and there's choice so i've worked i
worked for a network of homeless
shelters
the biggest problem was you could
literally walk up to a guy who was of
sound mind and body
who was just poor and say to him we have
a house
legit house we can put you in it we'll
get some clean clothes he's like no
really yup why because they don't want
to leave they like
they've met so it's not every single
person a lot of people just assume
homelessness is always this
this bad position that people have
unfortunately found themselves in
not realizing that some people choose to
do this it's like shawshank redemption
where they like being in prison yeah i
suppose but
i wouldn't even feel like being in
prison some of these people are like i
wake up
outside with fresh air i can walk
wherever i want
i can sleep wherever i want i have
nothing to worry about i can do what i
want
and so they end up sleeping and dragging
around crap and they smell bad
and it just creates homeless camps and
they like doing it well austin just
banned their homeless camps oh
uh last last week i'm not saying every
single homeless no no no of course
you're not of course
not so there was a uh so one of the
things you deal with is that
people refusing to go to the shelter
saying i won't do it i don't want to do
it i'm going to stay here
so then you get northern california
actually saying they'll seize the assets
of people who are homeless if they
refuse to like you know engage in
whatever
you have some people who are mentally
unwell yeah but think about this
let's say you just said you know what
don't care what you think don't care
what your abilities are we're gonna take
you we're gonna put you in a house
pipe bursts now you've got someone who's
mentally unwell sitting in a room
rocking back and forth as they're being
sprayed with water
and the floors are soaking up and who's
there to help them
who maintains the property these people
are children who don't understand
there is a massive economic system at
play that makes your
houses function that's why when you get
this black lives matter woman who's like
i'm gonna buy five houses
it's not just about the five houses it's
about the groundskeeper
it's about the building manager it's
about somebody's gotta be managing all
the taxes on this someone's gonna be
managing
the the day-to-day expenses the mail
that's showing up
there i'm sure she has a staff that's
dealing with this to maintain all of
these houses
or as she said her family is living in
them it's not just the house just
sits there and is full of money and so
what happens is you get people on
twitter with hundreds of thousands of
followers
posting something they absolutely do not
understand
by it's it's it's unfortunately it's
midway well that's why zoomers and
millennials get their education from
social media they're almost as bad as
boomers are with their
with facebook post but now on instagram
and twitter where it's just like a
literally a picture that's supposed to
explain a large
system and that's why you get a lot of
the beliefs on black lives matter to go
back to where we
first start a lot of it's like oh well
black people are 13
of the population but they're you know
this percentage of the well what
percentage of crime do they commit what
percentage
like there's a lot more than what you're
giving and what your but your education
comes from memes
that's a problem jeff bezos makes about
a million dollars a year
in benefits and his salary is eighty
three thousand dollars
he has stock he can't just sell the
stock he has contractual agreements and
obligations and they say like when
certain price points are reached he's
allowed to sell out certain amount of
the stock
so they say he made 13 billion dollars
in one day no the value of amazon as a
company went up 13 billion
but there is no circumstance in which
jeff bezos
could say i'm going to liquidate all of
my stock into cash right now for 185
billion dollars
it's not possible there's no
circumstance in which you could probably
even pull out 10 billion dollars
it is in weird increments it's small
it's imaginary
the funniest thing is how people who
don't
understand economics talk about
economics when they say things like i
remember when shane smith
of vice was a billionaire and i'm like
oh is he a billionaire why
because he sold a percentage of vice for
you know several 300 million dollars so
his
hypothetical holdings of that company
multiplied by
the investment percentage creates a net
worth of billions of dollars
congratulations that and
five bucks i'll get you a cup of coffee
at starbucks people don't understand
what wealth really means
they think that bezos has all this money
you can just throw around they think
zuckerberg has
money they're rich don't get me wrong
right they own like you know bezos has a
mega yacht that costs like half a
million dollars
because he is a billionaire but when
they come to you and they say like
we should tax 185 billion dollars of
bezos it's like he doesn't have that
but we should tax it anyway how would he
pay the taxes on that with a wealth tax
if you if you're charging him what one
percent he's got to pay
1.8 billion dollars he doesn't have that
in liquid assets then he should sell his
stock
he's not legally allowed to well we
should force it we should take it from
him okay so you're saying you want to
liquidate amazon
and lay off tons of people and shut the
company down because you don't like this
guy's rich
and then have no money and no resources
to help anybody it makes literally no
sense you want to reform the system fine
do your research stop wasting my time
because you're not arguing anything
but then you have to deal with the fact
that these people like bernie sanders
are in politics
and are making policy and then
millennials are just sitting here
complaining
and they vote and they vote this big
problem who are the zoomers
zoomers are generation z i think born
after 1997.
they're like in their 20s okay
yeah it's like the kids who are like
generations they're either in cells or
they're like
yeah there's no hair is it because they
used zoom a lot
no z i don't know zoomers this is really
boomers
zoomer so generally this is really crazy
uh zoomers are in cells
yeah no joke um i'm not trying to be
disparaging they don't have sex a lot
yeah there was a story from the
washington post showing that like more
than a third
up to like the age of 29 were virgins so
that doesn't include something i do
know a significant amount of 20 year old
men who are virgins like a sing
like i knew none when i was like a 23
year old or i knew like a handful who
were like were trying to get laid but
just couldn't
like 50 in bangkok couldn't help them
but now
i know a significant who are just
choosing not to have sex no it's not
even a choice
it's like uh they have no ambition they
have no ambition i went through
a celibacy phase and it was kind of my
choice but like three weeks long
yeah it was like five years it was a lot
of like hoping that i would meet someone
and i would spend like swipe right i
hope that this works out but that's not
how you find someone no they make it
happen there's the moment when you find
it they're not trying like they're
not trying to meet somebody like they
don't know it i i think they don't know
how
i don't know i don't know but like i'm
like let me help you i'm
one one of my friends i won't say his
name but he uh great guy
but he was like i'll make a dating app
and they're like name an interesting
thing about you and he wrote i love
virtue i'm like
are you joking me no one's gonna swipe
right i'm like
do a great impression of like apu on the
simpsons i don't know something like
don't do like this
you know it's funny have you have you
ever watched always sunny philadelphia
yes when he puts on his dating profile
like
he's like what do you what's your
favorite food he's like milk steak yes
but here's the funny thing in the show
it's like what what's milk steak
if you actually made a profile and said
you loved milk steak you'd get women
being like i love it's always sunny like
yeah something is not something yes
something nonsensical you have put that
don't put like your actual heart and
emotion like this like you'll get
destroyed in life it's like twitter like
you know be
it's a vultures twit tinder and all
these apps are
really really awesome i never had a
dating app and i wish like i didn't so i
never experienced like what that's like
but and it must be horrible to try to
make like general conversation but if
you can't make conversation in real life
right on everybody how the hell can you
make conversation on just an app or
i don't know some people are really good
at it and some people you know well i
don't know what the exact reason for it
but washington post
ran the story where they showed that uh
this is a couple years ago men
29 and under were substantially more
likely to be virgins
like 33 or more percent and i
i was we talked about this quite a bit i
think it's dating apps because
it opens up the dating pool for younger
women to older men that didn't used to
exist right a 35 year old guy
had very little access to 22 year old
women he'd have to go and lurk around
colleges was kind of weird
now it's just on the app boom there boom
yeah yeah could it also be a porn's big
deal but it could also be like
like you have a fear of being accused of
being dave for sure
yeah i'm sure that's part and like
zoloft like different
drugs that diminish sex drive but porn
there's a huge number of
like 20 year olds who have uh like
dysfunction down there they can't get it
up or whatever like
yeah because they're porn yeah there's a
lot of porn thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you